The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HAZEL SIVE: Some good questions.
Let's zip through quickly.
Why can't an initial
depolarization travel along
the length of the axon?
Last time, we went
through in detail
how a signal is transmitted
from the outside
to the inside of the cell by
ion flux across the membrane,
and then how that ion flux is
transmitted down the neuron.
Remember that the ions entering
the cell are just ions.
They'll diffuse away.
And so the depolarization
kind of dissipates.
And it then needs
to be regenerated.
The action potential,
each small depolarization
or the whole signal,
with a specific magnitude, the
reversal of membrane potential
going from about minus 60
millivolts, negative inside,
to plus 55 or 60
millivolts, positive inside.
Each of those is an
action potential.
And here is an interesting one.
Why doesn't the
membrane potential
stop at zero when sodium
rushes into the cell
during an action
potential, which
is what you'd expect if
sodium was just moving along
its concentration radian?
Because the potential's not
only governed by sodium influx.
There are chloride ions outside
the cell and potassium ions
inside over the duration
of the potential.
And as we'll discuss
briefly in a moment,
it's during the
rectification process
that you go back
to zero, and then
you reverse membrane
potential again.
Well, let's move on
to Nervous System 2.
And I want to cover two
things today, both of which
connect with last lecture,
and then move on to our topic
today.
We've drawn the analogy
of the nervous system
as a communication
system through the body
where there are wires, there are
connections between the wires,
and there are circuits
that need to be laid down.
Today, we're mostly going to
talk about the connections.
But I want to talk a little
more about pumps and channels.
And then we're going to
talk about the connections
between neurons, which
is also called synapses.
Let's begin with a little
more about pumps and channels.
And I want to briefly
summarize where
we were with talking
about an action potential,
and introduce one
last kind of pump--
of channel, excuse me--
that we didn't quite get to
at the end of last lecture.
And then we'll talk about the
pumps and channels involved
in synapses.
So in an action potential--
and the sequence of
an action potential--
we define three phases,
along the length of the axon
with regard to the
membrane potential
that was involved in
transmitting the signal,
along the very long axon,
intracellular signaling those
with arresting potential,
the threshold or the action
potential of the threshold
leading to the action
potential, and then the
question of repolarization,
resetting the membrane
potential, which is pivotal.
Otherwise, the cell
can't fire again.
And we talked about one
pump, which is really pivotal
for life-- we study it
in my own laboratory--
but one pump which
is on all the time
and which is involved primarily
in the resting potential
and the repolarization.
This is the sodium
potassium pump.
It pumps sodium out and
potassium in, but less sodium
out and potassium in.
And it is on all the time.
There are other channels
that are open all the time.
The key one are
potassium channels,
but there are also open
chloride and sodium channels.
And those are open all the time.
And depending on
the concentration
of the ions, and also
electrostatic repulsion,
which will counter sometimes
movement along a concentration
gradient, those are
involved in everything.
But primarily-- they're
open all the time--
but they are primarily involved
in setting up resting potential
and repolarization.
So we'll put some dots.
I'm going to dash the line
in the action potential area,
which indicates that those
pumps and channel, that pump
and channel are being
used and active,
but they're not pivotal
in those processes.
The one that's really pivotal
in the action potential
is the voltage gated
sodium channel.
We talked about this last time.
You can look a bit
more on the slides
that I posted with
regard to the ideas
behind how the channel is closed
at certain membrane potential,
how if the membrane
potential changes slightly,
there's a conformational
change in the protein.
And a pore opens
that allows sodium
to rush in down its
concentration gradient,
over a very small
area of membrane.
So the voltage gated sodium
channel allows sodium in,
and it is closed,
if we look at this.
It's open during an
action potential.
It is closed at resting,
but is ready to be open.
And then subsequently, it is
closed during repolarization
when the membrane
potential is reset.
And it's not openable--
it's not actually clear why--
there's some funny confirmation
and that pump is not ready to be
opened for some period of time
until the protein
structure resets itself.
And then it's openable.
So it's closed and it's
not ready to be opened.
And this is really
pivotal in making sure
that an action
potential traverses
in one direction along the
axon, and doesn't go backwards
as the ions diffuse backwards.
And then finally,
I want to mention--
or I want to tell you--
that there is a voltage gated
potassium channel that opens up
after the action potential.
And that is one
of the things that
is pivotal in resetting
the membrane potential
during repolarization.
The other thing that
is really pivotal
is this sodium potassium pump.
So the voltage gated
potassium channel
gets potassium out of
the cell in the area
where there has
been depolarization.
Your very positive
inside ions go out
along their
concentration gradient,
or along an
electrostatic gradient.
And so potassium goes
out, both in this case.
And so it is open
during repolarization,
and it is closed for
the rest of the time.
OK.
The thing you're going to have
to do with these channels,
that you will do in section
and with your problem set,
is to really work
through the kind of logic
behind what pump and channel
is doing what at what
stage of the action potential.
And then it will
start to make sense.
OK.
So we're going to
move on in a moment
and talk about the synapse.
But I'm going to talk about
the pumps and channels
during a synapse, and point
out to you that these pumps
and channels are being
used, but there are others,
which are really crucial.
One of them is the
voltage gated--
VG for voltage gated--
calcium channel.
And the other are a
series of ligand gated,
or second messenger gated.
Second messenger regulated,
let's say, not gated, ion
channels.
And these ligand gated, or
voltage gated second messenger
regulated channels, these things
are specific to the synapse,
and are specific to the
connections between cells.
So let's move on
to the major topic
today, which is this question
of the synapse, the connection
between cells.
And let me throw out some facts.
And then I'll show you
kind of a cool picture.
Neurons connect with one
another to make circuits.
That's the deal.
That's the wiring.
So how complex is this wiring?
I showed you a very
cool 3D reconstruction
of the brain that
showed you the packing
of the neurons in the brain.
But quantitatively,
what does that mean?
One neuron can connect with,
can synapse with up to 100,000
other neurons.
In the brain alone, there are
at least 10 to the 10th neurons.
It's not clear
really, to anyone,
how you put those
two numbers together,
whether you can multiply
them, and whether that's fair.
But whatever you
come out with, that's
a lot of connections,
just in the brain.
OK?
The number of synapses,
therefore, is huge.
So what kinds of
connections are there?
Let's just write this.
I'm not going to try to--
huge number of synapses.
There you go.
That's quantitative.
What are these connections?
We've talked a lot about an
electrical signal moving down
the axon.
But now I'm going to
tell you that most
connections between
cells are not electrical,
they're chemical.
And I told you last time
when we explored the reason
that you have these long
axons and intracellular
signaling rather than cells
all piled up next to one
another doing intracellular
signaling, that's slow.
I told you that last time.
And that's still
true in a synapse.
The connections
between the cells
is the slow point of
neural transmission.
There are electrical synapses.
And they are used
sometimes, but rarely.
They are fact because they are
connected by gap junctions, one
neuron to another.
And that allows ion flow.
But the thing about
electrical synapses
is that they're always open.
The cells are always connected.
They're unregulated.
And the thing about
the nervous system
is that it is
exquisitely regulated.
It is fine-tuned to respond
to the smallest stimuli,
both from within your
body and from without.
And unregulated synapses
will not do that for you.
So the flip of those
are chemicals synapses.
They are slow, their
diffusion limited,
and they're diffusion
limited of chemicals
that we'll discuss
in detail, that
are called neurotransmitters.
But they have the
wonderful property
of being highly regulatable.
And so the majority of
synapses in higher animals
are these chemical synapses.
And that's what we'll
talk about today.
This is a picture
which I really like.
It's a neuron where--
and these are the dendrites.
And here's the cell body
and the axon coming out.
And each of these dots
represents a synapse.
Well, it doesn't
represent a synapse.
It is, it's stained
for a protein that's
only found in synapses.
And you can see this tremendous
studding of the dendrites
with synapses, which gives
you a sense of the complexity.
OK.
It's really pivotal, when we
talk about the connections,
that we get some of
the principles correct.
So I want to spend a board going
through some of the principles
that we have to bear in mind in
thinking about the connections.
So let's think about this.
Here are neurons-- well,
let's have Neuron 1.
But we could actually
have Neuron 1 to n.
It doesn't matter.
It could be a whole
bunch of Neuron 1.
And along that one neuron,
or those bunches of neurons,
is coming an action potential.
And over here is Neuron 2.
And between them is a
connection, is a synapse.
And the thing that Neuron 2
has to decide when it connects
with Neuron 1 is
whether it's going
to make an action
potential, whether it's
going to send a signal.
That is the big decision
that this neuron has to make.
So Neuron 2 must decide to
make an action potential,
and it is a yes/no decision.
It's not a sort of
an action potential
or a half an action potential.
And so we need to remember
action potential facts, all
or none.
You either get an action
potential or you don't.
That means you get complete
depolarization or nothing.
And if you have a lot of action
potentials coming along Neuron
1, the way Neuron 2
can respond is not
to make a big action
potential, obviously.
But it can make a lot
of action potentials.
So a change in input where we
can call this action potential
from Neuron 1, the
input, a change
in input results in
an increase or change,
let's just say, a
change in the number
of action potentials per time,
or the frequency of action
potentials in Neuron 2.
Other facts, other
really key facts.
Resting potential can change.
Threshold potential and
the action potential,
as I've been belaboring,
do not change.
And you can see that nicely
in the slide, where here's
a neuron firing, and
this is a different way
of showing the neuron firing.
Here is the action
potential showing
as a spike of depolarization.
And then there's a
time, another spike,
another action potential,
wait, another spike, and so on.
Here is a neuron that's
gotten a lot of input.
And look at it.
It's spike, spike,
spike, spike, spike.
But if you look at the
height of that spike,
that is the
depolarization height.
It's the same within
the sensitivity
of the recording device for
each of these action potentials.
So I really like that slide
to exemplify these principles
that I've just
put on this board.
OK.
There are the principles.
How does it work?
Very cool.
This is really amazing.
Let's again have Axon 1.
We're going to have Axon 1 here.
OK?
Axon, oh, let's have axon
derived from Neuron 1.
And now we've got to
distinguish two different parts
of the axon.
And I'm going to draw
this on the board
and then I'm going to go through
it with you on a hand out,
because it's important.
There's an electrical
signal coming along Axon 1.
And you know that it
involves an action
potential via the voltage
gated sodium channels.
As that signal nears
the end of the axon,
the axon kind of bulges
out into a terminal,
and the voltage gated channels
change from sodium to calcium.
So here's the end of the axon.
And here you change to
voltage gated calcium
channels that are activated.
OK.
These voltage gated
calcium channels,
this is called-- actually,
let's put some terminology.
This is called the
pre-synaptic neuron.
And the voltage gated
calcium channels are
at the pre-synaptic terminus.
Now the thing about calcium
that we've mentioned
before is that it is a
mediator of exocytosis,
of having little
vesicles containing
proteins or other molecules
released from the cell.
These voltage gated calcium
channels increase intracellular
calcium and lead
to the exocytosis,
the release of
chemicals that are
contained in
vesicles at the end,
at the pre-synaptic terminus.
So the pre-synaptic
terminus contains vesicles
with neurotransmitter.
We'll talk about this in detail.
The voltage gated
calcium channels,
which increase
intracellular calcium,
lead to exocytosis release of
the neurotransmitter, which
is released outside the cell.
And that neurotransmitter
diffuses across the space
between Neuron 1 and Neuron 2.
It's about 30 nanometers.
And it diffuses
across the space.
And when it gets to
the other side to--
here's Neuron 2, called
the post-synaptic neuron--
when it gets to the
other side, and it'll
get to either the
dendrites or the cell body,
this neurotransmitter
binds to things
that we've talked about a
lot, it binds to receptors.
Those receptors plus
ligand do all the things
we've talked about
in many lectures.
They do something.
In this case, they can
do one of two things,
as we'll talk about.
But it all culminates
in changing ion flux
across the
post-synaptic membrane.
So the neurotransmitter
diffuses.
It hits the dendrites,
or cell body.
It binds receptors to change
ion flux, or ion movement.
And this eventually gets
turned into the action
potential decision.
OK.
So let's put some more on here.
Here's an electrical
signal from Neuron 1.
Here, this
neurotransmitter diffusion
is a chemical signal
across what is
called the synaptic cleft, which
is the space between neurons.
And the signal in Neuron 2
becomes electrical again.
So there's a conversion
device, which
converts electrical to
chemical to electrical signals.
All right.
Let's look at your
first handout and we'll
hammer this in in more detail.
Here's the action potential.
So let me stand here
in case you're--
they don't like me doing it.
OK.
Let me stand here.
Here's the action potential
coming along Neuron 1.
Voltage gated sodium
channels until you
get near the end,
when you switch
to these voltage gated
calcium channels.
Calcium flows in, leads
to exocytosis of vesicles
containing neurotransmitter.
The neurotransmitter diffuses
across the synaptic cleft,
binds to receptors on either
side, which changes the ion
flux into Neuron 2.
And there is an action
potential decision--
it's on your sheet--
an action potential
decision that eventually,
as we'll discuss, involves
voltage gated sodium channels
so that the cell
decides whether or not
it's going to fire
an action potential.
OK.
We'll talk about the
neurotransmitters
and the receptors in
more detail in a moment.
But I want to introduce
you to three concepts
of the synapse, which are
really very important.
The first is the
concept of summation.
And now we go back to the
notion that many neurons
can give signals to
another neuron, such
that that other neuron
is deciding yes, no, I'm
going to fire an
action potential
and transmit the signal.
The neuron that's receiving
all of that signaling
has to add up its inputs and say
what's the sum of the inputs.
Literally, it has to
add up the inputs.
So summation is the addition
of all synaptic input, which
is change in membrane potential
governed by change in ion
movement on a recipient neuron.
OK.
So the addition of
all synaptic input
on a recipient neuron,
or bio-recipient neuron,
if you like.
There's two kinds.
There's spatial
summation, which has to do
where the signal is received.
And so those synapses
that I showed you
in that picture of the
cell with all its dendrites
and all of those little dots
were all over the place?
Each of those little
dots is getting
a signal on the
dendrites, on the ends
of the dendrites, near the
cell body, in the cell body.
All of those inputs
have to be added up.
So where the signal
received, is received,
cell body plus dendrites, that
would be spatial summation.
And then temporal
summation means over time,
when the signal is received.
Over a period of a
millisecond or so,
all of those inputs to
the neuron are added up.
And the addition is
actually a simple one.
The addition is how much has
the membrane potential changed,
and overall, have you brought
the membrane potential
of the recipient
neuron up to threshold.
If you have, that
recipient neuron fires.
And if you haven't, it doesn't.
So the total
membrane potential--
so the answer of
whether to fire or not,
is the total membrane potential,
which is the decision.
And if it's threshold
potential, out of that,
an action potential results.
The addition, the summation
is done in the dendrites
and the cell body.
And the answer is read at the
place where the axon comes off
the cell body, which is
called the axon hillock.
So the sum is calculated
over all of the dendrites
plus the cell body.
But it is read at this thing
called the axon hillock.
And they only read
the axon hillock
is where the axon
leaves the cell body,
or originates from
the cell body.
And the reason that that
is an important place
is that that is where
the voltage gated
sodium channels are found.
It's only there.
They start at the axon
hillock, and they are present
all the way down the axon.
There are no-- and you
can look at your diagram
for this-- there are
no voltage gated sodium
channels in the cell
body or the dendrites.
So they can't fire
an action potential.
They can add up how
membrane potentials changed,
but they can't do
anything about it.
So the hillock is where the
axon leaves the cell body,
and where the voltage gated
sodium channels begin, begin,
and where an action potential
can therefore come out.
That's a bunch of sentences.
OK.
Couple more terms.
Excitatory and
inhibitory synapses,
excitatory and inhibitory.
It's kind of like a
simple math problem
where you're adding positive
numbers or negative numbers.
You know, you come out with
something that's either 0,
negative, or positive.
Same idea here.
When you add all these
inputs that a neuron gets,
it figures out what
it's going to do.
And the inputs can be either
pushing a neuron closer
towards an action potential,
closer towards threshold,
or pushing a neuron
away from being
able to make an action
potential, further
away from threshold.
Excitatory synapses bring
the resting potential
closer to threshold,
whereas inhibitory
bring the resting potential
further from threshold.
All right.
Here's where it gets
even more complicated.
One neuron can be making both
excitatory and inhibitory
synapses.
And depending on
which predominate,
the recipient neuron
will either be
told to fire or not
to fire, to make
an action potential or not.
So one neuron can make both
excitatory and inhibitory
synapses.
How does this work, you ask?
Well, you have all
the tools to know.
It's all got to do with ion flux
and which ions are flowing in
and which ions are flowing out.
And we can answer that by
looking at your next handouts.
In Number 2 of
your handouts, I've
shown you the synaptic cleft.
Here's a synaptic cleft.
And here are the voltage
gated calcium channels
opening to allow calcium
in and neurotransmitter
vesicle exocytosis.
Here is an excitatory synapse
bringing the resting potential
closer to threshold.
Let's think about that.
You want positive ions to
come in from the outside.
That would help bring
your resting potential
closer to threshold.
So there is some sodium
channels that can open,
maybe calcium channels that can
open-- not the voltage gated
ones.
And that would increase
the resting potential.
That would increase the
potential inside the cell,
bring it more positive,
closer to threshold.
Conversely, in an
inhibitory synapse,
you'd get a net inflow
of negative charges.
The chloride ions might
move from the outside in.
That would take, make
your inside of your cell
more negative and further
away from threshold.
You could also
get potassium out.
And that would, again,
make the inside of the cell
more negative and
further from threshold.
So you can see already I've
got four different channels--
they're not the ones
we've talked about before,
they're different ones--
four different
channels which can
modulate the membrane potential
on the recipient cell.
All right.
Let us move on now to
those neurotransmitters
and their receptors.
Neurotransmitters and
neurotransmitter receptors
are very cool because
they are probably
what makes us who we are
in terms of personality,
in terms of ability, in terms
of our interface with the world,
in terms of whether we're an
intrinsically happy or not so
happy person, er cetera.
Neurotransmitters, however,
are a class of molecule
we have previously encountered.
They are ligands, but
they're different ligands.
When we talked about
ligands previously,
we have largely been talking--
not entirely--
we've largely been
talking about peptides
or molecules that
are sort of a reasonable size.
Not always.
The steroid, the steroid
hormones are very tiny.
Neurotransmitters are
pretty much all very tiny.
And the thing that
you should know
is that you can have one or
many types of neurotransmitter
per synapse.
Here's another complication.
Neurotransmitters can
be peptides sometimes,
but they are very largely amino
acids, the same amino acids
that you build proteins
with, nucleotides,
or other small molecules,
like the kinds of synapses.
Synapses are excitatory
or inhibitory
because of the kinds
of neurotransmitters
that they're making.
So there are excitatory
neurotransmitters.
Glutamate, glutamate,
glutamate, glutamic acid--
OK, the same one we've
talked about before--
and adenine are both
examples of excitatory,
are examples of excitatory
neurotransmitters.
Glutamate is involved
in being alert.
Adenine is involved
in being sleepy.
And one of the things
that caffeine does
is to counteract the
effects of adenine
so that it's thought
to competitively
interact or competitively
inhibit adenine function.
Inhibitory
neurotransmitters, something
called GABA, gamma-Aminobutyric
acid, and glycine
are the two major CNS,
Central Nervous System
neurotransmitters.
GABA particularly is an
anti-anxiety neurotransmitter.
And things like Xanax, which
I will get to today or Friday,
are things which will be
agonists of GABA function.
And sometimes,
neurotransmitters can be
both excitatory and inhibitory.
Acetylcholine,
for example, which
is involved in connections
between nerves and muscles.
Neuromuscular connections,
and also found in the CNS,
can be both excitatory
and inhibitory.
And serotonin-- and
I'll put dopamine
on the same line for
space-- serotonin
and dopamine, both
of which are kind
of feel good
neurotransmitters, also
involved in alertness
and other things.
For dopamine-- locomotor
activity movement--
they can be either
excitatory or inhibitory.
What do they look like?
Let me go on and then I'll show
you some pictures in a moment.
All right.
So how can something be
excitatory and inhibitory?
What's downstream of
these neurotransmitters?
The receptors.
Good job.
All right.
Neurotransmitters,
ligands bind receptors.
And the way the
neurotransmitters
affect what they're
going to do is
by binding the
appropriate receptor.
So here are the receptors
for the neurotransmitters.
And like the
neurotransmitters, there
can be many different
kinds per synapse.
There are two classes of
receptors that you should know.
One are ion channels.
They're receptors which
bind the neurotransmitter,
and they open up.
They're ligand
gated ion channels.
But the other kind
are not ion channels.
They bind the
receptor and then they
activate a second
messenger system,
as we talked about before.
And it's the second
messenger system that
later on opens an iron channel.
They have names.
So two classes, one
are the iron channels.
They're called
ionotropic receptors.
So they're ligand
gated ion channels.
And the thing about these
is that their response
is very rapid, in the
millisecond range.
There's another class
of those receptors
which activate ion channels.
They are called metabotropic.
It's the concept that is
more important than the term,
but I'm giving you the
term for completeness.
And they act via
a second messenger
system that almost always
involves G proteins.
And these are slow.
Their response is at least
a second, often much greater
than a second.
OK.
And let me, as the last
thing I'll tell you today,
I'll show you-- if
we have a moment I'll
show you some
pictures-- but I want
to tell you that one
neurotransmitter can activate
different kinds of the receptor.
So one neurotransmitter can
activate greater than one type
of receptor.
And this was implicit
in the notion
that neurotransmitters could be
both excitatory and inhibitory.
For example, serotonin
binds to no fewer than 14
different receptors.
And one neuron can express
probably not all 14,
but it could probably express
five different serotonin
receptors.
And they do different things.
One of them is a ligand
gated sodium channel.
Another type is G
protein coupled, so
including both metabotropic
and ionotropic receptors.
And to throw out at you
the last couple of slides,
here are some of these amino
acids and small molecules
that are neurotransmitters.
And this really exemplifies
what I've said on the board.
So I'm going to stop here now.